I like to start speaking when I have
about 3,000 known words in a language.
This is what I'm finding right now. Some
people may start to speak earlier, some
people may want to delay it. It depends
on your personality, it depends on the
language you're learning, how different
it is from languages that you already
know, how much common vocabulary there is
and so forth. But eventually you should
speak. You should schedule with one of
our tutors, or if we don't have a tutor
in that language, you can use one of the
other communities online such as italki,
which offers native speaker
tutors. Whether you're with a LingQ tutor
or someone at italki, make sure you get
a report with the words and phrases, at
least some of them, the words and phrases
that you had difficulty with so that
this report can be imported into LingQ
and that you can study it and hopefully
eventually improve. But it takes a long
time to get to a level of fluency, so
make sure you're patient but do force
yourself at some point to start speaking.